I have a little shopping problem I like
to buy stuff I like to buy clothes
jewelry first we need to find out why do
you like it I like swag but you got such
a swaggy face you don't need all those
things I look I think when you think
about money the biggest thing is it's
more than okay to buy nice things it's
not okay to buy nice things when you
can't afford them you know you got this
three two
young Dylan we are here with garyvee and
Mia V and today we're gonna ask him
questions we're gonna all of us are
going to ask each other questions in
this big bowl of slime it's really been
so cool let's start okay first you're
gonna go first here we go I like the
color of this slime
[Music]
this
is this look at this
all right
yeah okay all right okay so what does
the Super Bowl mean to you the Super
Bowl for me personally as a Die Hard New
York Jets fan means it's something I'm
desperate and I mean desperate to get to
one day
I've I've been a fan of the Jets since
1982 long before you two were years were
born exactly think about that think
about how long I've been wanting this
and the Jets have never gotten to the
Super Bowl we've been to four AFC
Championship Games the game right before
the Super Bowl and we've lost every one
of them in my life so for me the Super
Bowl represents the Ultimate Dream as a
die-hard fan I'd love to hear that how
about you Mia you know I just like to go
to the Super Bowl with my family and we
just sit there and watch the game it's a
big event like a big event that I've
been to so I'm really honored to be
there and I just like to sit there and
watch the game
I love that I love that okay Mia
getting in the Slime getting in there
okay all right man
as as you can before someone notices
what's that mean
as you can before someone notices maybe
it's like a trick question I feel
tricked
let's get another one yeah let's get
another one
here we go
okay what are you most scared of I am
most scared of the people that I love
the most being sick
that is scary that and snakes oh yes
snakes scare the crap out of me because
they can hide anywhere right yeah and
they're just like they're unpredictable
and they bother me
how about you
my doll your dog scares you own dog oh
hold on let me explain so my dog he is
he cannot get away from my parents like
he loves to lay on them so that means I
can't get any love from my parents
because he's trying to protect them like
he doesn't let me oh like that yes like
that type of dog you feel me so are you
afraid of your dog are you afraid of
your dog taking your spot
hold on so like and like you said
unpredictable and sometimes he sneakily
like like he'll like I'll be on the
couch my mother and he'll just look at
me I'm like I know that's fair I'm ready
run away then you just gets going oh
yeah gets going because he doesn't want
me to be around my parents and you're
right I am afraid that you're gonna take
my spot because I'm being a little bit
older he's the baby so the baby's always
scary how about for you
um I'm afraid when I watch a scary movie
and then I go to bed I always watch
scary movies for a bit I don't really
know why and then I go to bed and I hear
noises like my house starts moving and I
don't really know what the noises are
from and it doesn't really happen on the
nights where I just go to bed normally
it always happens in the night when I
watch scary you may want to cut down on
those scary movies a little bit not real
rap my turn all right here we go
we go
man the iconic slime this is a real
otter all right here we go
who's on your playlist
what do you think Mia uh I think I don't
really know I have a lot of people on
playlist like the most random artist
I've never heard before like if I pulled
up I ran us off from my playlist and you
played it I probably you may not even
know who Name the artist how about you
should be adding songs yeah okay so what
you'll see on my playlist is a bunch of
Drake big Drake fan Big Jake fan uh
Kendrick Jay-Z and um that hip-hop life
yeah yeah I love it I love and species
you know I'll be getting in my field
sometimes so I gotta listen to some
scissor to get over my Fields you feel
me speaking of speaking of feels I'm
listening to Hungry Eyes from Dirty
Dancing on repeat like crazy right now
and speaking about hip-hop I'm playing a
ton of Polo G right now oh Polo G is all
in my playlist
that Piano Man
yep
okay all right
uh what's your favorite sport and why
my favorite sport is football to watch
my favorite sport to play are two sports
right now I've finally gotten back into
basketball I broke my foot like four
years ago playing basketball and so I
was off of it for a minute but I'm
really back I played yesterday for a
couple hours it feels good I'm also
playing pickleball
pickleball is exploding it is kind of
like tennis meets ping pong and it's an
exploding Sport and I I think you two
need to pick it up yeah
oh you are that's all and do you play a
little tennis yeah I play tennis you
should really really really pay
attention to pickleball you would love
it all right shut up Matt what about you
Mia I think I love volleyball I mean it
feels like a crime cannot say football
yeah but I love volleyball I play it
um back in Madison town and I love it
for me
I was six because I'm a big big football
fan but besides football I'm really got
soccer yeah soccer I'll say soccer
um you know I like Neymar yeah Neymar's
a beast okay so yeah I'm really good at
that and um you know I just love
watching highlights of football players
because like they got amazing shrimp and
feet the dribble moves are insane it's
just so crazy to see and watch it I
agree it's a great sport do I pull
another one I mean you go ladies first
okay all right if you weren't playing
football what would you be doing
spending time with my family I love like
having dinners with fam uh I love
working I'm very fortunate the biggest
thing that I wish for the two of you
besides good health is that as you get
older you just enjoy what you're doing
so many people settle and do things that
they don't love so I'd be working be
with my family those two things stand
out how about you my man for me same for
real just making sure my family safe you
know I also want to be example for kids
not even my family I really all the kids
yeah all the kids really I just want to
be examples and yeah spread a good
message and when I'm not on this Earth I
want people to still remember me I love
that once that Legacy life I respect
that all right let's get one more in
here
let's go
here we go
we go last question what Nick character
do you think is the best at football
is it bad that I'll say Nate or me
I'll say Nate though
yeah that's a good answer I mean I don't
really know what I'd answer with I think
that oh it's such a question
um you know there's this one episode in
SpongeBob a really strong worm that big
Pokemon that had a father oh hey yo that
one would destroy the whole field I mean
for me I'm much older than y'all so when
Nick first hit the scene Mr wizard was
this real science character that I think
actually was really crafty and I think
we put together the best game plan and
win in football so Google that because
you definitely have no idea what I'm
saying right I know that I know that but
I'm trying to keep it real with the
audience and they some of us I see the
smiles back there we remember the OG
days of Nick so thank you for having me
guys no problem yeah thank you but oh
it's me and you and us
are you really trying to buy the Jets
I'm really trying to buy the Jets
I love to see you but thank you thank
you so much such a little slime
love you thank you everyone